MICHALE FEE: OK, good morning.
So far in class, we
have been developing
an equivalent circuit
model of a neuron,
and we have extended that model
to understanding how action
potentials are generated.
And, more recently,
we extended the model
to understanding the propagation
of signals in dendrites.
So today we are
going to consider
how we can record activity,
record electrical signals
related to neural
activity in the brain,
and we're going to
understand a little bit
about how we can, in particular,
record extracellular signals.
So that will be the
focus of today's lecture.
So, so far in
class, we have been
analyzing measurements of
electrical signals recorded
inside of neurons.
For example in the
voltage clamp experiment,
we imagined that we were placing
electrodes inside of cells
so that we could measure
the voltage inside of this
of cells.
But it's actually quite
difficult, in general,
to record membrane potentials
of neurons in behaving animals,
although it's
certainly possible.
It's much easier to record
electrical signals outside
of neurons.
In this case, we can actually
record action potentials.
And so those kinds
of recordings are
made by placing metal electrodes
that are insulated everywhere
along the shank of the electrode
except right near the tip.
And if we place a metal
electrode in the brain,
we can record voltage
changes in the brain
right near cells of interest.
So in this case, we can
record from action potentials
of individual
neurons in behaving
animals and various aspects
of either sensory stimuli
or behavior.
So this kind of recording is
called extracellular recording,
and we're going to go through
a very simple analysis of how
to think about
extracellular recordings.
So recall, of course, that
when we measure voltages
in the brain, we're always
measuring voltage differences.
So when we place an electrode in
the brain near a cell, we are--
we connect that electrode
to an amplifier.
Usually, we use a differential
amplifier that gives us--
that provides us
with a measurement
of the voltage
difference between two
terminals, the plus terminal
and the minus terminal.
So we place-- we connect the
electrode to the plus terminal,
and we connect
another electrode,
called the ground electrode,
that can be placed in the brain
some distance away
from the brain area
that we're recording from,
or the surface of the skull.
So we're measuring the
voltage that's near a cell
relative to the voltage
that's someplace further away.
Now, the voltage that we measure
in the brain, voltage changes,
are usually or always
associated with current flow
through the extracellular space.
So we can analyze this
in terms of Ohm's law.
So, basically, the voltage
changes that we are measuring
are going to be associated
with some current through
extracellular space times
some effective resistance
in the extracellular space.
And you remember from
previous lectures
that the effective resistance
of extracellular space
is proportional to the
resistivity in extracellular
space times a length scale
divided by an area scale.
So how do we think about
what kind of voltage changes
we might expect if we placed an
electrode near a cell that is
generating an action potential?
So let's start with
a spherical neuron,
and let's give this spherical
neuron sodium channels
and potassium channels so
that it can generate an action
potential.
So during an action potential,
we have an influx of sodium,
followed by an
outflux of potassium,
And that influx
of sodium produces
a large positive-going change
in the voltage inside the cell.
So you can see that during
the rising phase of the action
potential, we have
sodium flowing in.
But at the same time,
we have current flowing
outward through the membrane in
the form of capacitive current.
Now, these two currents,
the sodium ions
flowing through the membrane and
the capacitive current flowing
outwards through the
membrane, are co-localized
on the same piece of membrane.
And so there's no
spatial separation
of the currents flowing
through the membrane.
And as a result of
that, there's actually
no current flow in
extracellular space,
and so there's no
extracellular voltage changes.
The first lesson from
this is that, if we
were to record an extracellular
space from a spherical neuron
with no dendrites and no
axon, we would actually not
be able to measure any
extracellular voltage change.
Now let's consider
what happens if we
have a neuron with a dendrite.
So in this case, when the sodium
current flows into the soma,
that current, part
of it will flow out
through the capacitive--
through capacitive current,
but part of that current
will flow down
the dendrite, then
out through the membrane
through capacitive
current back to the soma.
So we have a closed circuit
of current, current flowing
into the soma out
through the dendrite,
and then back to the soma
through extracellular space.
So in this case, if we write
down the equivalent circuit
model of what this looks like--
this is the somatic compartment,
this is the dendritic
compartment-- we have--
in our earlier calculations of
current flow through processes,
through dendrites, we were
neglecting the extracellular
resistance, but in this case
we are going to include that,
because that extracellular
resistance is what provides--
is what produces a voltage drop
in extracellular [? space. ?]
But during an
action potential, we
have current flowing
in through the soma,
out through the inside
of the dendrite,
back out through the
membrane of the dendrite,
and through extracellular
space back to the soma.
The voltage drop across this
region of extracellular space
will be proportional to this
extracellular current times
changes in
extracellular voltage.
So now, we have a simple view
that we have current flowing
into the soma in a region--
from a region around the soma.
So we have effectively what
is known as a current sink.
So we have charges
flowing into the soma
in the region around the soma.
That current then flows
out through the dendrite
and appears in
extracellular space
in the region of
the dendrite, and we
call that a current source.
So we have a combination
of a current sink
and a current source.
And you can see that the
current in extracellular space
is flowing from the current
source to the current sink.
So in this case, you can see in
our simple equivalent circuit
model that the voltages are
more positive in regions
corresponding to
current sources,
and the voltages are
more negative in regions
of extracellular space
corresponding to current sink.
Current is flowing from--
in extracellular
space, this current--
current is flowing from
the region of the dendrite
to the region of the soma.
The voltage here
is more positive,
the voltage here
is more negative.
Now, let's take a look at
understanding the relationship
between the
extracellular voltage
change and the intracellular
voltage change.
So let's just write
down the equation
for the voltage drop across
this extracellular space.
That voltage drop is
just the external current
times some effective
external resistance.
The external current
is just the sum
of a capacitive current
and a resistive current
through the membrane
of the dendrite.
So we can write down
that voltage drop is now
proportional to an external
resistance-- extracellular
resistance, I should say.
So the-- so we
can now write down
an expression for
these two currents
as a function of
membrane potential.
And you recall from
earlier lectures
that the capacitive current
is just given by C dV dt,
and the membrane
ionic current is
given by some conductance,
membrane ionic conductance,
times the driving potential.
Now, in an action potential,
voltage change is very rapid.
So dv dt is large.
And, in fact, this
term generally
dominates over this term
in an action potential.
And so what we find is that the
voltage change in extracellular
space is proportional
to the derivative
of the membrane potential.
And we can see that
this is the case.
In earlier experiments
from Gyorgy Buzsaki's lab,
they were able to
record simultaneously
from a cell intracellularly--
that's shown in
this trace here--
and the extracellular
voltage recorded
from a microwire electrode
placed near the soma.
Extracellular recording
is shown here,
that the extracellular
signal is actually
quite close to the derivative
of the intracellular signal.
Now, why is this
voltage negative?
Because the membrane
potential near the soma here,
the voltage here goes negative
because during the rising phase
of the action potential,
we have sodium ions
flowing into the soma
from extracellular space.
A current is flowing out
of the dendrite out here
and traveling back through
extracellular space
to the soma.
So, again, the soma is
acting like a voltage sink,
and so the voltage is going
negative near the soma.
So now let's take a look at
what happens when we have
synaptic input onto a neuron.
So it turns out you can also
observe extracellular signals
that result not from
action potentials
but from synaptic inputs.
So let's take our
example neuron and attach
an excitatory synapse
to the dendrite.
In this case, when the
synapse is activated,
if the cell is hyperpolarized,
when a neurotransmitter is
released onto the postsynaptic
compartment of the synapse,
it turns on conductances
which allow current to flow
into the dendrite.
That current flows down
the dendrite to the soma,
flows back capacitively
out through the soma
and back to the synapse
through extracellular space.
So you can see
that in this case,
the region near the synapse
looks like a current sink
as charges are
flowing into the cell.
The region near the soma
looks like a current source
as current flows out of the soma
and back to the current sink.
And see that, in this case,
you have charges flowing
into the cell, and
that should correspond
to a decrease in the
extracellular voltage.
For the soma, you
have positive charges
flowing into extracellular space
from the inside of the cell,
and that corresponds
to an increase.
OK, things look different when
you have an inhibitory synapse.
In the case of an
inhibitory synapse,
for example if GABA is released
onto this GABAergic synapse,
it opens chloride channels.
Chloride is a negative iron
that flows into the cell,
but that corresponds to
an outward-going current.
So now we have the region around
the inhibitory synapse looking
like a current source.
Current flows through
extracellular space
to the soma, where the soma
now looks like a current sink.
And so in the
presence of activation
of inhibitory inputs in
the-- near the dendrites,
you actually have an increase in
voltage of extracellular space.
While near the soma, you have
a decrease in the voltage.
One of the important
things to consider
is that, in the
discussion we've just had,
we've been thinking about
an individual neuron, how
current sources
and current sinks
appear as a result of synaptic
activity and action potentials
around a single neuron.
But in the brain,
neurons are not isolated
but are in the tissue next
to many other neurons, that
are also receiving
inputs and spiking.
So it turns out that the types
of electrical extracellular
signals that you see
in the tissue depends
very much on how different
cells are organized spatially.
So in some types of tissue,
for example in the hippocampus
or in the cortex, cell bodies
are lumped together in a layer,
and the dendrites
are collinear and are
organized in a different layer.
So this is called a
laminar morphology.
In this case, many of
the synaptic inputs
arrive onto the dendrites,
and currents then
flow into the somata.
And in this case, these
extracellular currents
are reinforced.
They reinforce each other,
and they sum together
to produce very large
extracellular voltage changes.
So now let's turn
to the question
of how one actually records
neural activity in the brain.
So let's go back to
our experimental setup
now where we have
an electrode placed
near the soma of a neuron.
And that electrode is connected
to a differential amplifier
or an instrumentation
amplifier, giving us
the voltage difference
between the extracellular
space near the soma and
the extracellular space
somewhere far away.
So we-- so this
amplifier then measures
that voltage difference
and multiplies it
by a gain of
typically, let's say,
a couple hundred, or
1,000, or even 10,000.
We then take the output
of that amplifier
and put it into an analog
to digital converter, that
then measures the voltage
at regularly spaced samples
and stores those voltage
digitally in computer memory.
So in analog to
digital converters,
the voltage is sampled at
regular intervals, delta t,
corresponding to
some sampling rate,
which is a frequency or a rate
that's given by 1 over delta t.
So the rate at which
the samples are acquired
is referred to as the sampling
rate or sampling frequency.
So if we were to record
the extracellular voltage
in a region of the
hippocampus, we
might see a signal that
looks very much like this.
These are data from
Matt Wilson's lab.
The signal has a
number of features.
So you can see that there
is a slow modulation
of the signal that
actually corresponds
to the theta rhythm in a rat.
That slow modulation
of the voltage
is actually caused
by synaptic currents
in the hippocampus
you can also see
that there are very
fast deflections
of the voltage corresponding
to action potentials.
So, once again, this is
about a second's worth
of data of intracellular--
sorry-- of extracellular
recording from rat hippocampus,
and we can see both
slow and very fast
components of this signal.
The extracellular-- the action
potentials, you can see,
are very brief.
They typically last
about a millisecond.
If we were to look at
the amount of power
at different frequencies in this
signal using a technique called
measuring the power spectrum,
which we will cover in more
detail later in
class, you can see
that there is a lot of
power at low frequencies
and much less power
at high frequencies.
So this is a representation
of the amount of power
at different frequencies.
So we can actually extract
the fast and slow components
of the signal using a technique
called high pass and low pass
filtering.
So what we're going
to do is we are
going to develop
this technique that
allows us to remove
high frequency
components from
the original signal
to reveal just low-frequency
structure within the signals.
So how do we do that?
Well, basically,
what we do is we're
going to start by using a
technique of low pass filtering
that works basically
by convolving
this signal with a kernel.
What that kernel does is it
locally averages the signal
over short periods of time.
So what we do is we
take that signal,
and we're going to
place this kernel
over the signal at
different points
in time, average together.
We're going to
multiply the kernel
by this signal at different
points of time-- in time,
and plot the result down here.
So let me explain
what that looks like.
So let's say this is
the original signal.
You can see that it's
a little bit noisy.
It's fluctuating between
1 and 3, 1, 3, 1, 3.
And then, at a
certain point here, it
jumps to a higher
value, 5, 3, 5, 3, 5.
So, intuitively,
we would expect low
pass filtered version of
this signal to be low here,
and then jump up to
a higher value here.
Now, here's our kernel.
This is a representation of a
kernel that looks like this.
The kernel is 0,
0.5, 0.5, and 0.
And, basically, what
we're going to do
is place the kernel at some
point in time over our signal,
multiply the kernel
by the signal time
element by time element.
So you can see that the product
of the kernel with the signal
is 0 here.
0 times 1 is 0, 0.5 times 3
is 1.5, 0.5 times 1 is 0.5,
and 0 times 3 is 0.
So that's the
product of the kernel
and the signal within
that time window.
Then sum up that--
the elements of that product.
0 plus 1.5 plus 0.5 plus 0 is 2.
I'm going to write down
that sum at this point
in the filtered output.
Now, what we're going to do
is just slide the kernel over
by one element and repeat that.
And I also added the earlier
values of the output here.
So now we slide the kernel
over by one, we repeat.
We get 0, 0.5, 1.5, and 0.
Sum that up, we get a 2.
And write down that
filtered output down here.
So you can see that the low pass
filtered result of this signal
is 2 everywhere up to here.
Now, if we slide the kernel
over one more and multiply,
you can see we get a 0, a 1.5.
Here's 0.5 times 5.
That's 2.5.
0 times 3 is 0.
And the sum of that, the sum
of those four elements is 4.
Write down a 4 here.
And if we keep doing that, all
of the rest of those values
is 4, which you can verify.
So you can see that
the low pass filtered
version of this signal,
filtered by this kernel,
is 2 up to this point,
and then it jumps up
to 4, which was consistent
with our intuition
about what low pass
filtering would do.
So that was low pass filtering.
Now, how would we
high pass filter?
How would we extract out these
high frequency components
from the data, throw away
the low frequency components?
Well, one way to think about
this is that we actually--
we can get rid of
the low frequency
elements simply by
subtracting off the low pass
signal that we just calculated.
So how do we do that?
So we're going to
use this kernel here
to do our high pass filtering.
And notice that this
kernel has two components.
It has a square component
that's negative,
and it has a delta
function at 0.
So you can see that
this negative component
of this high pass filter looks
a lot like the negative of our--
looks like the negative
of our low pass filter.
So if we were to
take this kernel
and instead use
a kernel that was
the negative of that
kernel, like this, then what
we would get is the
negative of this low passed,
of this filtered signal.
So this part right here, this
part of the high pass filter,
is producing the negative
of our low pass filter.
Now let's take a look
at this component here.
This component is a delta
function with a value of 1
at the peak.
You can see that if you
convolve that kernel
with your original
signal, it just
gives you back the
same original signal.
So what we've done is this
component simply gives us
back the original signal.
This component subtracts off the
low pass version of the signal.
What we're left with is
the high pass version.
Let's look at what that does
to the spectrum of our signal.
You can see that,
the high pass, we've
gotten rid of all of these low
frequencies, all of the power
at low frequencies,
and we're left
with just the high frequency
part of our signal.
And if we go back and look
at the spectrum of what
the low passed
signal looks like,
we can see that the low passed
output retains all of the power
at low frequencies and gets
rid of these high frequency
components [AUDIO OUT].
Low passed signal has no
power at high frequencies.
So once we have extracted
high pass filtered
version of the signal, you can
see that what you're left with
are action potentials.
So what we're going
to talk about now
is how you actually extract
these action potentials
and figure out when
action potentials occurred
during this behavior.
Next thing we're going
to do is detect--
we're going to do
spike detection.
So, basically, the best
way to detect spikes
is to look at the
signal, plot the signal,
and figure out what
amplitude the spikes are.
So look at the voltage of the
peak, the peak of the spikes.
And then set a threshold
that consistently
is crossed by that peak
in the spike waveform.
So here are the individual
samples associated
with one action potential.
You can see that a
voltage right about here
will reliably
detect these spikes.
And then, basically, you
write one line of MATLAB code
that detects where
this voltage crossed
from being below your threshold
on one sample to being
above your threshold
on the next.
Now what we can do
is, once we detect
the time at which that
threshold crossing occurred,
we can write down that
threshold crossing time
for each spike in our wave form.
The spike here, we
write down that time.
That's t1.
If you have another
threshold crossing here,
you write that time down, t2.
And you collect all of these
spike times into an array.
So we can now represent
the spike train
as a list of spike times.
So we're going represent this
as variable t with an index
i, where i goes
from 1 to N. Now,
we can also think of spike
trains as a delta function.
So you may remember
that a delta function
is 0 everywhere except at the
time where the argument is 0.
So this delta function is
0 everywhere except when
t is equal to t signal.
That's when t is equal to
the time of the signal.
At that time, the delta
function has a non-zero value.
So we can write down
this spike train
as a sum of delta functions.
So the spike train
is a function of time
is delta of t minus
t1, corresponding
to the first spike, plus
another delta function at time
t2 corresponding to
that spike, and so on.
So we can now write down
mathematically our spike train
as a sum of delta functions,
one at each spike time.
We can also think
of a spike train
as being the derivative
of a spike count function.
So a spike count function
will reflect the number
of spikes that have occurred
at times less than the time
in the argument.
So if this is our spike train,
then prior to the first spike,
there will be zero spikes
in our spike count function.
After the first spike, then
we'll have a spike count of 1.
And you can see that you get
this stairstep increasing
to the right for each
spike in the spike train.
Since the integral of this
spike train has units--
the integral over time
has units of spikes,
you can see that the spike
train, this rho of t,
has units of spikes per second.
So now let's turn
to the question
of what we can extract
from neural activity
by measuring spike trains.
So one of the
simplest properties
that we find about
cells in the brain
is that they usually
have a firing rate that
depends on something,
either a motor
behavior or a sensory stimulus.
So, for example, simple cells
in primary visual cortex,
of the cat in this case, are
responsive to the orientation
of visual--
of stimuli in the visual field.
So this shows a bar of
light, but represents
a bright bar of light on a
black background, actually.
And you can see that if
you move this bar in space,
at this orientation this
neuron doesn't respond.
But if we rotate the--
if we rotate this bar of light
and move it in this direction,
now the cell responds
with a high firing rate.
So if we quantify
the firing rate
as a function of orientation
of this bar of light,
you can see that the
neuron has a higher firing
rate for some orientations
than for others.
That property of being tuned
for particular stimulus features
is called tuning,
and the measurement
of that firing rate as a
function of some parameter
is called a tuning curve.
So you can see that in
primary visual cortex,
neurons are tuned
to orientation.
And the tuning curves of
neurons in primary visual cortex
often have this characteristic
of being highly responsive
at particular orientations,
and then smoothly dropping off
to being unresponsive
at other orientations.
So in a similar--
similar to the way that
neurons in visual cortex
are tuned to orientation,
neurons in auditory cortex
are tuned to
different frequencies.
So, for example, in
the auditory system,
when sound impinges
on the ear, it
transmits vibrations
into the cochlea.
Those vibrations enter
the cochlea and propagate
along a basilar membrane,
where vibrations
of particular
frequencies are amplified
at particular locations,
and the membrane
is unresponsive to vibrations
of other frequencies.
So if you [? learn ?]
from neurons
in visual cortex and you--
sorry-- in auditory cortex
and you play a tone,
so this shows a philograph
of a auditory stimulus.
At some frequency, you can
see that this neuron spiked
robustly in response to that.
So Individual neurons are
tuned to respond robustly
at particular frequencies
but not other frequencies.
And you can see that
different neurons
are selective to
different frequencies.
So you can see that this
curve representing one neuron,
that neuron is most
active for frequencies
around a little bit
above 5 kilohertz,
whereas other neurons are
most responsive to frequencies
around 6 kilohertz, and so on.
So we saw an example now of
how firing rates of neurons
in sensory cortex are sensitive
to particular parameters
of the sensory stimulus.
This property of tuning applies
not only to sensory neurons
but also to neurons
in motor cortex.
This shows the results
of a classic experiment
on analyzing the spiking
activity of neurons
in motor cortex
during the movements,
during our movements in
different directions.
So this shows a manipulandum.
This is basically a
little arm that the monkey
can grab the handle here
and move that arm around.
The monkey's task
is to hold that--
hold this arm at a
central location.
And then a light comes
on, and the monkey
has to move this
manipulandum from the center
out to the location of
the light that turned on.
And so the experiment is
repeated multiple times
where the monkey has to move
to different directions.
You can see here
the trajectories
that the monkey went through
as it moves from the center
location out to these eight
different target locations.
And in this experiment,
neurons were
recorded at different regions of
motor cortex, and the results--
the resulting spike
trains were plotted.
In this figure, you
can see what are
called raster plots, where--
for example, for movements
in this direction,
five trials were
collected together.
So each row here
corresponds to the spikes
that a neuron generated during
movements from the center
to this direction.
You can see that the neuron
became active just after
the [INAUDIBLE],, indicating
which direction was turned
on, and prior to the
onset of the movement,
which is indicated [AUDIO OUT].
You can see that the
neuron responded robustly
on every single trial to
movements in this direction.
But the neuron responded
quite differently
in some other direction.
So you can see that the
response to downward movement
was quite weak.
There was essentially no
change in the firing rate.
And you can see the to
movements in other directions,
for example to the
right, were associated
with an actual suppression
of the spiking activity.
So I should just point out
briefly that these spikes here
and here, before and after
the onset of the trial,
are spontaneous spikes that
occurred continuously even when
the monkey wasn't engaged
in moving the handle.
So we have a
spontaneous firing rate,
the trial initiates an
increase in firing rate,
and then a recovery to
the baseline position.
So you can see that
these motor cortical
neurons exhibit tuning for
particular movement directions.
And we can quantify this now by
counting the number of spikes
in this movement interval,
and plotting that
as a function of the
angle of the movement.
And when you that, you
can see that movements
in particular
directions, in this case
[AUDIO OUT] by degree direction,
resulted in high firing rates,
whereas movements
in other directions
resulted in lower firing rates.
So in order to do this
kind of quantification,
we need to be able to--
we need to understand
a few different methods
for how we can actually
quantify firing rates.
The simplest thing
that I just described
here is to just count
the number of spikes
in some particular
interval that you decide
is relevant for your experiment.
So, for example, let's say
we have a stimulus that
turns on at a particular
time, is-- it stays on,
and then turns off
at some later time.
On different trials of that--
or different presentations
of that stimulus, you
can see that the spike
train- that the neuron spikes
in a somewhat different way.
But you can see that
this sample neuron here,
that I just made up, you can
see that, in general, there
is a vague increase in the
firing rate after the onset
of the stimulus.
So we can quantify that by
simply setting a relevant time
window and counting the number
of spikes in that time window.
So we're going to
set a time window
T from the onset of the stimulus
to the offset of the stimulus,
and simply count the number
of spikes on each trial.
So N is the number of spikes
that occurred on the ith trial.
The brackets here represent
the average over that quantity
i, which is trial number.
So we're going to count the
number of spikes on the ith
trial and average
that over trials.
So then, once we have
that average count,
we simply divide by the interval
T that we're counting over,
and that gives us a rate.
Now, you can see that the number
of spikes, the firing rate
is not constant.
So you can see in this
little toy example
here that, the
way I've drawn it,
that the spike rate
increases at stimulus onset,
and then it decayed away,
which is very typical.
So you're throwing away
a lot of information.
Now, the way that we just
quantified that firing rate,
we just counted spikes over the
whole stimulus presentation.
But if we want to get more
temporal resolution in how
we quantify the firing
rate, we can actually
just break the
period of interest
up into smaller pieces,
count the number of spikes,
the average number of spikes in
each one of these smaller bins,
and divide by the interval
of these smaller bins.
So, for example, we can have--
we can count the number of
spikes on trial i and then j.
And we can average
the number of spikes
in the jth bin, overall trials.
So that's just
the average number
of spikes in this
first bin, for example,
and divide by the
interval delta T.
And so now you can see that you
have a different rate, finer
temporal resolution.
So, for example, if you
look at the analysis
that Georgopoulos did
in that 1982 paper
for the arm movements
of the monkey,
they broke the trials up
into small bins of about 10
or 20 milliseconds each,
counted the number of spikes
in each one of those bins,
divided by that bin width,
and computed the firing
rate, spikes per second,
in each one of those bins.
You can see that they
did one other thing here.
The average firing
rate during each bin
in which we've subtracted
off the firing rate
in the pre-stimulus period.
So that is, very
typically, what you'll
see in a neuroscience
paper describing
the behavior of
neurons to a stimulus
or during a motor task.
And so we can use similar
tricks to estimate
the firing rate of neurons in
just a continuous spike train.
So not all neuroscience
experiments
are done in trials like this,
where we present a stimulus
and then turn it off.
Some trials-- some experiments
are done, for example,
where a movie may--
a monkey or an animal
might be in a movie
where stimuli are
presented continuously.
So you don't have this
clear trial structure.
So we can also
quantify firing rates
in cases where we just
have a continuous spike
train without trials.
And we can do that,
again, by just taking
that continuous spike train and
breaking it up into intervals.
So there will be N
sub j spikes in bin j,
and then the bin has
some width delta T. Now,
one problem that you can
see immediately from this
is that the answer you get
will depend on where you place
the boundaries of the bin.
So if you take all these bins
and you shift them over by,
let's say, half of--
shift them over
by delta T over 2,
you can see that you can get a
completely different set of--
a different set of firing rates
for this same spike train.
So there's not a unique answer.
So another way to do this
is to quantify firing rates
in bins that are shifted
to all possible times.
So, for example, we
can take a window
where we have 0 everywhere
except within this window.
We can now multiply
the spike train.
Well, one way to do
this would simply
be to count the number of
spikes within that window,
and then shift the window over
and count the number of spikes,
and shift the window over and
count the number of spikes.
And now you get
a count of number
of spikes in each
of those windows
for all the windows
that have width delta T,
but we've shifted it
in small time steps.
But how can we describe
that mathematically?
Well, you may recall
that this, in fact,
looks a lot like a convolution.
We're going to take
this square kernel,
and we're going to multiply
it by the spike train
and count the number
of spikes, take
the integral over that product.
And you can see that
that's basically
going to give you
the number of spikes
within that window
from t1 to t2.
So, for example,
in this case we're
going to use a square window.
The firing rate is
just going to be
given by the number
of spikes divided
by the width of the window.
And that's just 1
over delta T times
the integral t minus
delta T over 2 to t
plus delta T over 2,
sliding that gradually
over the spike train.
So we're effectively
convolving our spike train
with this rectangular kernel.
And that's what it looks
like mathematically.
The firing rate is the
convolution of the spike train
with this smoothing kernel.
So, as I mentioned,
that's just a convolution,
and we're convolving our spike
train with this square kernel
of this width.
So that is the mathematical
expression for a convolution.
the firing rate is
just the convolution
of this kernel with
the spike train.
And, again, the
kernel is 0 everywhere
except within this window,
minus delta T over 2
to plus delta T over 2, and it
has a height of 1 over delta T
such that we make the area 1.
Notationally, we often write
that as a star, rho star K.
Now, in this case we were
convolving our spike train
with a square kernel.
The problem with
a square kernel is
that it changes abruptly
every time a spike
comes into the window or
drops out of the window.
A more common way of
quantifying firing rates
is to convolve the spike
train with a Gaussian kernel.
So instead of using
a square kernel here,
we're going to use a Gaussian
kernel that looks like this.
The kernel is just defined
as this Gaussian function.
And it's normalized by
1 over sigma root 2 pi,
and this normalization gives
area under that kernel, 1.
So it's still essentially
counting the number
of spikes within that window.
It's again just a
weighted average
of the number of spikes divided
by the width of the kernel,
but there's less
weight at the edges.
It has smoother edges,
and that gives you
a less steppy-looking
result. So let me show you
what that looks like.
So here's a spike train.
If we take fixed bins and
compute the firing rate
as a function of time,
it looks like this.
If we take that spike
train and we convolve it,
and that estimate
of firing it would
depend very much on where
exactly the windows are placed.
On the other hand, this
shows the firing rate
estimated with a square
kernel of the same width.
And you can see that it shows
a much smoother estimate,
a smoother representation of the
firing rate varying over time.
And if you take that
same spike train
and you convolve
it with a Gaussian,
then you get a function
that looks like this.
And we think of this as
perhaps better representing
the underlying
process in the brain
that produces this
time-varying firing
rate, this time-varying
spike train,
than either of these two.
You don't really think that
the firing rate of this neuron
is jumping around in
rectangular steps.
We think of it as
being some kind
of smooth, continuous
underlying function
that represents maybe
the input to that neuron.
Youll see that in these
estimates of firing rate,
we had to actually choose
a width for our window.
We had to choose a bin size.
We had to choose the width
of our square kernel here,
and we had to choose the width
of our Gaussian kernel here.
And you can see that
the answer, actually,
that you get for firing
rate as a function of time
depends very
strongly on the size
or the width of that kernel
that you choose to use.
And now we smooth it
with a Gaussian kernel
that has a width, a
sigma, of 4 milliseconds.
So that's the standard
deviation of the Gaussian
that we use to smooth
the spike train.
And you can see
that what you get
is a very peaky estimate
of the firing rate.
So that spike produces
this little peak.
But the question is,
what's the right answer?
How should you actually
choose the size
of the kernel to use
to estimate firing
rate for your experiment?
The answer is that it really
depends on the experiment.
So neural spike trains
have widely different
temporal structure.
So, first of all, neuronal
responses aren't constant.
Firing rates are not
a constant thing.
Neurons-- neural firing
rates are constantly
changing depending on the
type of stimulus that you use.
And different types
of neurons have
different temporal structure in
response to the same stimuli.
So, for example, this
shows the response
of four different
neurons to stimuli, to--
four different neurons
in rat vibrissa
cortex in response to
whisker deflections.
So this shows a
raster, a histogram
of firing rate as a function of
time for one neuron in response
to a deflection of one of
the whiskers right here.
So the whisker is at
rest, deflected, and then
relaxed back to its
original position.
You can see that
this neuron shows
a little burst of activity at
the onset of the deflection,
and it's fairly persistent
throughout the deflection.
Here's another neuron
during a deflection.
Increased activity at the
onset of the deflection,
followed by a fairly
persistent increased spiking
rate throughout the deflection.
Now, a different neuron was
quite a different behavior.
So this neuron shows a brief
increase in firing rate
just at the time of the
deflection, a little increase
of firing rate when the
deflection is removed,
and [INAUDIBLE] no
activity that persists
during this constant
part of the deflection.
Here's another neuron.
This neuron was primarily active
at the onset of the deflection.
Here's another neuron
that was silent
at the onset of the
deflection, and then gave
a robust response.
Neurons, the changes
in firing rate
are not of a
particular timescale.
Different neurons have
different time scales
on which the changes in their
firing rate are important.
But let's come back to our
example of our auditory neuron.
Here's the spiking
of an auditory neuron
during the presentation of an
auditory stimulus [INAUDIBLE]
right here.
This neuron-- in fact,
you can't see it here,
but this neuron shows
spiking at a particular phase
of the auditory stimulus,
much like the auditory
neurons that we discussed for
sound localization in the owl.
So if you plot the firing
rate of this neuron
as a function of time during the
presentation of this stimulus,
you can see that the
firing rates are rapidly
modulated in time.
You can see that, at particular
phases of this stimulus,
the firing rate is very high.
And then just a
millisecond later,
the firing rate is very low.
So in this case, you
can see that the spikes
are locked temporally
at particular phases
of the stimulus.
That's reflected when you
make plots of firing rate
as a function of time.
It's reflected in
various modulations.
The neurons are firing
at a particular time.
So this corresponds
to a case in which
we would say that the
spike timing is precisely
controlled by the stimulus.
It's, in many ways, more natural
here to think about spike times
as being controlled rather
than spike firing rate being
modulated.
So you can see here that
sensory neurons, neurons
can spike more in response
to some stimuli than others.
Motor neurons spike more
during some behaviors more
than others.
We can think about
information being carried
in the number of spikes that
are generated by a stimulus
or during a motor act.
Now, all neurons exhibit
temporal modulation
in their firing rates.
They fire more during a movement
or after the presentation
of a stimulus.
Sometimes that information is
carried by slow modulations
in the firing rate.
For example, the response
to different oriented bars
is carried in the average
firing rate of the neuron
during that particular stimulus.
And we can refer to
that kind of code
and that kind of representation
of information as rate coding.
We can say that information
about the stimulus
is carried in the rate, the
firing rate of the neurons.
But in other cases,
like the auditory neuron
that we just saw, we
can see that information
is carried by rapid,
by fast modulations,
rapid changes in
spike probability.
And in that case, we
often say that information
is coded by spike timing.
So a common question that
you often hear about neurons
is whether they're
coding information
using firing rate
or temporal coding,
rate coding versus
temporal coding.
Really, this is a
false dichotomy.
You shouldn't think about
neurons coding information one
way or the other.
These are just-- really just
two limits of a continuum.
The brain uses information
at fast time scales
as well as slow time scales.
And how do we determine,
how do we know
what's important for the brain?
What time scales are important?
And the answer to
that question really
comes from understanding the
way spike trains are read out
by the neurons that
they project to.
What time scale is relevant
for the computation
that's being done in the
system that you're studying?
What are the
biophysical mechanisms
that those spikes act on.
To understand these
questions, then that's
the appropriate
level of analysis
to think about how
spike trains are
important for our sensory
coding and for motor behavior.